bang bang
what's up guys lunch money time that was
good
uh well while she's trying to get rich
for us let's just try to get our lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent polina ebiloba marinova
pompliano
p-i-m-p what's up
what's up get money get paid by the way
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block fi
if you go and you open a block fi
account you put some money in you
then can earn interest on that money
that money will earn up to eight point
six percent
apy that means that if you put a hundred
dollars in
and you leave it there all
year you'll earn 8.6 percent if you put
more money you still earn eight point
six percent it's amazing
go and check it out block five dot com
slash pomp or lunch money or lunch money
that's the same place
blockfy.com pomp go check it out you can
also buy and sell crypto i'm still
getting a us dollar loan against your
crypto collateral
i'm still very offended if you type in
paulina does it go there i don't think
so no blockfi.com
all right i'm an investor i sit on the
board it's awesome i use it
go do it what's up with our topics u.s
debt has reached its highest level
compared to the size of the economy
since world war ii and is projected to
exceed it next year the result of a
giant
fiscal response to the covet pandemic
i feel like we're setting all these
records we don't want to be setting
there are three other countries that are
notorious
for having more debt than their economy
japan italy and greece
[Music]
not exactly the uh company
that you want to keep when it comes to
this specific statistic
uh on top of that the idea of this year
uh the debt to ratio ratio
is going to be 98 percent you can
partake
and in that situation that would also be
the highest
since world war ii so so but it's
different
right why is it different well because
the surgeon borrowing
so far isn't creating angst among
amongst investors or hampering the us
ability to borrow more
investors have gobbled up u.s treasury
assets drawn to their relative safety
moreover interest rates are expected to
remain low suggesting the government
still has plenty of room
to borrow maybe
looking good maybe look
the short answer is this time is not
different
in terms of it's still not great
situation
but it is different in the sense of
there are not very many people who have
lived through a global pandemic
where we've all been forced to sit at
home because of a government mandated
lockdown
and then had a government step in with
historic quantitative easing and
interest rate manipulation that then led
to
a rocket ship in public equities so all
of those factors combined create a
situation that we just haven't seen
before
that's fine but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the core
components of economics of financial
markets of
asset valuations changes it just means
that you've got to
uh navigate the markets uh given the
current environment
and we'll see who's right and who's
wrong navigate those markets
well that's why they make markets is
because people are literally betting
money on
one or something else happening uh and
the market is ultimately the referee the
market will determine who's right and
who's wrong
right yep all right what's up all right
so
bill ackman spak smack
should we every time we talk about
special spec aflac
okay bill ackman approached airbnb about
a merger with his blank check
company but the home rental site
rebuffed
the billionaire investor and said it
prefers a traditional
ipo i thought airbnb was going to do a
direct listing
that's what oh is that a traditional
idea no that's why they rub off so
there's three ways you can go public for
those that don't know
you can go through a traditional ipo
process right which basically means you
sell shares into the market
uh while you go public and you can raise
capital that way another way that you
can do it is a direct listing
up until last week you could basically
just go and say hey start trading my
shares but i'm not raising any money i
thought that's what airbnb was gonna do
that is what they're gonna do they said
they prefer traditional ipo
uh no they said that they uh yeah
what this article may not be accurate
but in other articles they talked about
a direct listing because they told
that's what they told
employees that they were going to do was
a direct listing so maybe now they're
changing their mind but for sure they
told employees
that they were going to uh do a direct
listing uh then the the last step
is through a spac basically what happens
is there is a
uh entity that is publicly listed that
entity then it can acquire a private
company and essentially bring that
company now into the public markets just
through acquisition
uh bill ackman who is a famous uh hedge
fund manager
uh one of the best investors in the
world washington square he
raised a four billion dollar spec
earlier this year
so the way that a spac works is that
four billion dollars normally is going
to buy
uh somewhere between you know it's going
to buy a minority position in most cases
so less than 50 of a business meaning
that he's got to go find companies that
are worth at least 8 billion
or more many cases it's around 20
is what you're buying of the business so
in that case bill ackman would
essentially have to go find something
that's worth somewhere between 16 to 20
billion dollars in the private market
there's just not that many companies
that big and i have a question so as a
public market investor
when i see a spec like that i
buy with the idea that he's going to
make
a purchase of a company that i like i'm
just kind of betting on him
there's a couple there's a lot of
complexity i don't want to get into all
the details right now
uh because it gets pretty uh in the
weeds but basically there is
um investors who commit capital up front
so the four billion dollars
bill ackman doesn't actually have the
four billion dollars at first he goes
and he finds a deal
and then he brings it to them and says
hey i've negotiated this deal here's
what it looks like here's how it works
uh basically will you guys approve it
right and those investors can
is this done in the private market uh
it's not done
on the public market in terms of the
stock price right so what's happening is
he goes to those investors and he says
here's the deal here's all the terms
like
give me your money if you approve it
right and then they give them the money
and he does the deal
they can say no we don't like this deal
and uh and remove it
when you're dealing with people like a
bill ackman when you're dealing with
billions of dollars like this
he's not going to propose the deal
unless he knows that he's going to have
the votes to get the approval
but there's also a public stock price as
well yeah that public stock price is
basically people speculating on what's
going to happen and what's going to buy
they're betting on him buying something
good uh
well so i don't think that his spac is
actually publicly trading it there's all
kinds of complexities around the timing
whatever but long story short is bill
ackman's
back if he was to buy a company like
airbnb would eventually become the
airbnb stock
important to know spax have a limited
amount of time i forget is 18 months or
something
to make a purchase so they have to um oh
yeah usually about two years
they don't identify a target until after
shares begin trading
yeah so you can't like basically he
can't say oh i'm buying this company now
the shares trade and then go do the deal
uh there's a lot of regulation around
this um so look
he's got four billion dollars he's got
to go buy a company that you know
minimum
i'd say is 10 billion
i mean look he could do it but i just
don't see that happening
uh i think that he's very interested in
going after
um us-based technology companies that
are private right now that want to be in
the public market do we
know why airbnb would rebuff his offer
because they don't want to do a spec
right so the one of the complexities of
doing a spac
is there's all kinds of things around uh
warrant coverage and stuff
so basically uh bill ackman actually did
a pretty good job from what i remember
the way he structured it was very um uh
kind of fair
but there's a lot of spacks that are set
up in a way where uh basically the
people who uh manage the spac
they end up actually um you know owning
more of the company getting a great deal
they can multiply their money very
quickly
uh and it's it's an okay deal for the
company or to a good deal
but it's a great deal for the spac
sponsor and so there's a lot of
companies that are saying that i don't
want to go do that and so they're going
to go do either direct listing or
traditional ipa
got it cool yep robin it's your spec
class for the day popular trading
platform robinhood is under
investigation related to its disclosures
around its practice of selling clients
orders
to high frequency traders i think i know
about
two words of that sentence so what are
they doing what essentially happens
is uh when you're on robin hood and you
go and you make a
trade so let's say you want to buy 100
shares of something the best way to
think about this is
those hundred shares are then uh put on
an exchange
to sell right uh but what happens
is with robinhood rather than robinhood
paying for the ability to put a trade on
the
the exchange the exchange actually pays
robinhood
they say hey you could go to all these
exchanges but come to ours right come to
this marketplace
and we'll pay you for that order flow
right the orders that you're putting in
now the reason why they're doing that is
because the marketplace for the exchange
turns around and they
sell those hundred shares the the
information about the hundred shares to
a high frequency trader
so in a very very simple over
generalized example
let's say that um the let's just pick a
stock let's say tesla stock
is trading and the bid in the ask
basically the amount of
dollars that somebody wants for the
shares versus the amount of dollars
somebody was willing to pay for the
shares
has a spread of one dollar so somebody
wants to sell shares at a hundred
dollars and somebody's willing to buy
the shares at 99
so that spread is there what will happen
is
the high frequency traders know okay
you're about to sell 100 shares
they'll go in and they will buy 100
shares at 99
or at a 99 and then they will turn
around
and they will sell it to you at 100.
right or
i'm sorry i got it backwards basically
what they'll do is they'll capture the
um they'll capture the spread because
they know you're about
equals difference the difference yes so
they know you're about to sell so
they're able to basically uh what they
call
front run you so they go and they make a
trade before your order gets executed
and they can make money
but they're only scalping like literally
you know point one percent one percent
they just do this hundreds of thousands
of times and end up making a lot of
money so basically the sec's probe into
robin hood
is at an advanced stage and could result
in a fine of more than 10 million
dollars if the company agrees to settle
according to the wall street journal
selling order flow
is not illegal in itself and most
brokerages do it
however more of robin hood's overall
revenue comes from the practice than
other
brokers so what well robin hood's whole
innovation was we're going to do
zero cost like zero commission trading
which was unheard of at the time you
used to have to pay every time you
traded and then everybody followed suit
right tdm married trade
all of the yes and so the the big thing
that happens here is they're not getting
in trouble for doing this
because again it's legal you can do it
it's just there's a lot of questions
around are they actually disclosing it
to the individual traders and the reason
why this is
maybe not ideal for traders is yes you
don't pay a fee
uh in order to trade but what happens is
somebody's front running you and when
they front run you
you don't get best execution of pricing
so that means that you actually could be
buying something at a higher price than
you would have otherwise
and therefore you're quote unquote
losing or you're paying
for somebody to front run you yeah right
and so it's just a different way for the
company to make money
they're getting in trouble because uh
people feel like they haven't actually
disclosed this appropriately
we'll see what happens guys because i
stay true to my word
look at what i did today ah oh wait
this way this one ah instant pot oop
instant pot he was covering it but i got
you i got you i brought the crockpot out
for you
is it a crockpot it's an instant pot is
that the same thing no no okay all right
what's up with bumble okay
tell them about the meal i made last
night really great um fox made stuffed
peppers
okay bumble the dating app is preparing
for an
ipo that could seek evaluation of six to
eight billion dollars
and it could come early next year and
bumble reportedly has a hundred million
users worldwide
it's a lot of people yeah it's a lot of
people i mean
this whole story uh from the beginning
has been really
weird so for people that don't know
bumble was started by
whitney heard wolf one one of the three
founders of tinder there was a big
falling out
she went off she started bumble but she
didn't start it by herself she started
in a concert with uh this guy
russian businessman who owned a bunch of
other dating apps that were really
successful
uh and then eventually they like
acquired the app
yeah so i forget all the stories but
basically long story short bulma's been
very successful right
they claim to have 100 million uh users
and they're looking for a six to eight
billion dollar valuation
i mean makes sense yeah i read this in
um warning brew so i'll give them credit
but i thought this was really good
so basically they were like you know how
back in the day it used to be
taboo to me on dating apps and people
would lie about like oh we met at a bar
like it wasn't a dating app
but now in covet times it's taboo to say
you met somebody at a bar
instead it's safer to me on a dating app
i would be
dangerous on dating apps like i would
just hit people
sup that's not dangerous that's
literally every dude on every dating app
oh they say pretty much not to me
oh that's fine well let me know if
anyone messages you on the dating app
i'll let you know um okay
uh okay got real quieted so
amazon is open amazon is opening a new
whole foods store in brooklyn
but it won't open to the public they're
being called ghost
grocery stores uh the whole foods store
will be permanently online
only charged with fulfilling online
grocery orders for customers in the
brooklyn
area the store which opens on tuesday
blah blah blah
grocery delivery continues to be one of
the fastest growing businesses at amazon
we're thrilled to increase access to
grocery delivery it's never been more
important
i love this idea the ghost grocery i
just again when you go to online first
business
where you now take the space if you
think of a grocery store
how much room in like square
footage-wise is reserved for the
cashiers
is reserved for the walking space uh so
customers feel good
is reserved for like cap end space you
have these big displays all this kind of
stuff
the second you remove the need for the
person to go into the grocery store
you completely reimagine how the grocery
store is set up
and you can set it up for efficiency and
now it's just
it's a warehouse that's all it is it's
just a warehouse i understand but i
think that a lot of people
when they go to the grocery store a lot
of those displays a lot of those things
help you discover new items and new
products and things like that
do you think that you can discover more
things by walking around the grocery
store or online them suggesting
everything to you
yeah and they're likely to actually get
to know you better like right now
like targeted ads well the way that i
think no well just think of like a
recommendation
so like the way i think about the
grocery store is they create a
one-size-fits-all
display right so when you walk in i walk
in and everybody else walks in we all
see the same display
right and the way that the grocery store
is set up and there's a bunch of
engineering and data science that goes
into
you know seeing certain colors that make
you hungry and all this kind of stuff
that's all fine
but it's one size fits all what the
internet allows them to do is
dynamically change
so when you go to the site you see
something different than i see
and it's more personalized to me it's
actually a better experience i
understand and this is a little bit out
of the grocery store
realm but like i'm just reminded of the
story of sarah blakely building spanx
and like moving her display around to
being different whatever because it was
a new product and nobody knew about it
fair like if i'm online they can target
me i can find out about spanx or
whatever
what if you just are never targeted for
items for women so therefore you never
know what to buy me
for a gift not that you should buy the
spanx i'm just saying in general like
because it's hyper personalized to you
you end up not discovering new things
that maybe
you yeah but but again you're not going
to the grocery store to buy
your wife a gift so what ends up
happening is they can suggest
other types of food that you may like
okay right
chips thing that you might like but you
don't know because
you've never searched chips you sound
like a boomer
the internet is better it's better in
every single way the only way that it's
not better
is the social experience of going to the
grocery store if you like want to get
out and walk around
that's fine but from an efficiency
standpoint from a business standpoint
this is way better
yeah i'm gonna start ordering groceries
online all right what's next
hey okay you know how prince harry and
meghan markle
left the royal house
we out see okay so they have reportedly
signed a multi-year deal with
netflix and a price tag was not revealed
but the contract is rumored to be valued
at more than a hundred million
dollars well what they got a hundred
million dollars for a company that
doesn't exist yet
they moved to l.a yeah i mean this is
this makes sense
you think what are they gonna do yeah
this makes a lot why
why yeah because basically if you think
about what they're doing here
is they're saying hey we're famous
we have a great pulse on culture and
our na our fame and that pulse on
culture will allow us to create amazing
things
we'll do an exclusive deal with you but
you give us the money up front right
give us a hundred million dollars
and we're gonna take the hundred million
dollars we're gonna create a production
company we're gonna create all this
great stuff oh
whatever from netflix standpoint if
harry and megan started this and were
successful and then went to go sell them
the content later it would be way more
expensive so you're saying do it up
front
and they're basically making a bet that
like it's like a venture capital
investment you're basically investing in
something before it's
actually because netflix is making the
bet yeah they're making a bet that
harry and megan will be successful in
doing a production company
and therefore let's basically buy
exclusivity today at a cheaper price
than we would get it later
right and we don't want to create a
bidding war we don't want to do any of
this it's like look
sure it now does it work who knows but
that's the logic here and i think that's
fine i just
uh i don't know they left the royals
they claimed they wanted more privacy
yet
here they are exposing themselves on
netflix
well it doesn't say it doesn't say
necessarily that they're going to
they they might make documentaries about
other people it doesn't mean that
they're going to do anything for
themselves
okay all right ready yeah so people felt
bad for me so somebody on
youtube gave me a joke all right what
bad joke do they give you
okay thank you chao here's a random lame
joke for paulina
hey okay a mushroom walks into a bar
the bartender says hey we don't serve
your kind here
and the mushroom says why not i'm a fun
guy
thank you that was a good one did you
even get the joke yeah like
fungus like fungi you didn't get the
joke
no i do get true funny guy fun guy i got
it
it just wasn't funny the first person
who sends me a joke that makes me laugh
he'll be my friend forever all right
guys that's it for lunch wendy today
well while she's trying to get rich for
us just trying to get our lunch money
right
well you don't salute with your life
and you also don't do like a limp wrist
you're doing no i'm doing it a 90 degree
angle
i can't get up there though all right
guys that's it for today we'll see you
guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends